TEAM.
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED.
HE'S KIND OF THE THE TIME DOWN D
AND BACK, GRIND AND THE PUCK,
DOES IT GET ACROSS THE NEUTRAL ,
SCORE!
POWER PLAY GOAL!
RIGHT UNDER
THE STICK OF SPURGEON. DIFFERENT
THOUGHT IT JUST GOT
KNOCKED OUT OF HIS HAND.
>> Jeff: AA POWER PLAY GOAL. NOR
THE FAR CIRCLE, SPUN AROUND,
ELVIS PUNCHES AT
FIALA DROPS IT THERE.
FRONT.SHOT IN
NOW MARCUS FOLIGNO FROM BEHIND
THE NET,
DUMBA, SANTA HAD AT THE SIDE  S.
PERFECTLY, HARD
SHOT LOW, TIME IT PERFECTLY,
THAT STICKSE WILDCOLE SILLINGERT
OFF, AND KURALY AWAY TO CENTER,T
DEEP. YOUNG
PLAYER TO WATCH, 20 YEARS OLD.
FIALA OUT TO CENTER.
FIALA ACROSS THE LINE.
DEEP IN THEVIS UP AGAIN IN
THE FINAL MINUTUT BOONE JENNER S
TWO BODIES WITH HIM A
LOT OF EMOTION, NOW BOTH THESE
SIGN. ON A
PUCK IS SENT AHEAD, WE HAVE NOT
SEEN V
THE CBJ CHANT. CHANGE.
WERENSKI IS READY
GAUDREAU WAS WITH HIM.
DOWN IS E!
ACROSS THE GOALMOUTH AND CORNERR
FIALA.
CHINAKHOV LOOKING FOR ON
ELVIS A
CHANGEUP SHOT.
>> Jeff: COST ON THEIN FIALA, SD
SHOOTER, 4 FOR 8,
CHINAKHOV.
KAHKONEN BACK PEDALS
FIVE-HOLE.
JUST ENOUGH SPACE ON THAT AS A
CATCHES THE PAD AND
JACKETS WIN AND THERE IT IS!
THE SAVE